willkommen liebe zuschauer bei history
live dem historischen gold auf phoenix
bis max reich der schrecken europas
darüber diskutieren wir heute zum
zweihundertsten geburtstag unseres
titelhelden mit der historikerin
gabriele hoffmann dem historiker michael
stürmer und dem stalker johannes willms
eva über bismarcks wirken sprechen
wollen wir uns erst mal fragen was war
das eigentlich für ein mensch sie hat
sich ja nun unter anderem mit dem
privatmann bismarck beschäftigt wie
eisern war er denn der sogenannte
eiserne kanzler
dazu gibt es zwei sachen zu sagen das
eine ist dass es eigentlich kein
privatmann bismarck gibt sondern wie es
mag es immer zugleich eine öffentliche
gestalt gewesen
das kann man ganz konkret an seiner
wohnsituation ansehen im auswärtigen amt
auch später in der reichskanzlei
privatleben und amt gehörten zusammen
und das zweite ist mit dem eisernen
kanzler
das hat sich so fest gesetzt so ein
bisschen als charakteristikum bismarcks
aber das würde ich ganz gerne ausgeben
denn es geht zurück auf eine große rede
ich nehme an das ist darauf zurückgeht
ich weiß keine andere kein anderes
beispiel auf seine erste große rede als
ministerpräsident in einer sehr
angespannten situation in preußen indem
er sagte die welt guckt nicht nur oder
europa puck nicht auf preußens
parlamentarismus also auf seine
liberalität sondern guckt auf seine
militärische stärke und das worauf es
ankommt ist nicht das gerede im
parlament sondern preußen sich
durchsetzt mit eisen und blut darauf
geht dies geschichte geht die geschichte
mit dem eisernen kanzler zurück und die
liberale presse war außer sich sein ein
abenteurer ein kriegstreiber
es war ein ganz schlechter einstand und
von da aus kann man seine persönlichkeit
auf und entwickeln jetzt macht wenig
zeit hatte ich ja gefragt
persönlichkeitsprofil was gegen das
klischee vom eisernen kanzler steht
können sie uns denn da weiter
er war ein hochsensibler mann hatte
natürlich auch ein privatleben vor der
ministerpräsidenten und reichskanzler
zeit und in dieser zeit war er erst mal
ein glänzender briefe schreiben das
wissen wir genau weil die briefe
meistens veröffentlicht sind
er war ein hochsensibler kämpfer der
sich für politik anfangs gar nicht
interessiert denn er wollte musik machen
wie ich sie liebe und nicht wie sie im
orchester vorgeschrieben wird
er hatte also einen großen unstillbaren
ehrgeiz aber wie sollte er da hin kommen
und dann hat er auch ein sehr
interessantes liebesleben und konnte
sich lange zeit nicht richtig
entscheiden zwischen der fürstin orloff
und dem dienst am preußischen staat und
erst als das wasser in potsdam sozusagen
bis ganz oben stand da hat er sich dann
für den staat entschieden und von da an
kommen alle diese klischees und wenn man
das so sagen das wort vom eisen und bei
ihm direkt vor das die berühmte rede im
budgetausschuss des posten landtags
nicht durch reden und mario tietz
beschlüsse werden die großen fragen der
zeit entschieden sondern durch eisen und
blut und wenn sie heute die welt
anschauen von mittel aus bis zur ukraine
dann fürchte ich es eine ziemlich
realistische vorstellung
sie klingt natürlich schockierend aber
vielleicht sieht trotzdem war
darüber werden wir noch reden ein
hochsensibler liebhaber erwähnt aber ihr
buch trägt den untertitel dämonen der
deutschen wie passt das denn zusammen
doch das passt eigentlich ganz gut
zusammen natürlich war ein hochsensibler
liebhaber und die geschichte mit
katharina urlaub die auch noch in
frankreich sich zutrug also genau in
biarritz und umgebung ist ja durchaus
von romantischen die bereits kann man
nachvollziehen
ich wollte noch etwas zu privat man
sagen worauf man natürlich hat in der
reichskanzlei gewohnt dabei hatte was
heutige politiker mit großem leid
erfüllen wird
er hat die gelegenheit zu mehrmonatigen
urlauben auf seinen gütern genommen und
was war da der war privat man
selbstverständlich ich meine natürlich
hat er da auch telegramme bekommen und
hat denkschriften geschrieben aber wer
auf seinen gütern sitzt hat ist
sozusagen im urlaub und terminale bad
kissingen
er hat sowohl auf seinen gütern
gearbeitet als auch in diesen jeweils
mehreren monaten mit denen er in denen
er mit dem könig im bad war seine
mitarbeiter haben sind nur gefreut mit
akten er hat dort auch gearbeitet und zu
seiner zeit bevor er nun
ministerpräsident war es nicht so
gewesen dass er ein so selbstbewusster
in den startlöchern stehende
machtpolitiker war sondern als er seine
frau heiraten wollte die heiraten wollen
um in die politik zu kommen und um ihr
politisches netzwerk zu kommen da war
ein trunkenbold er war ein
schuldenmacher er war ein schürzenjäger
er hatte sich sämtliche politischen
aussichten verbaut
und aus dieser wirklich schlimmen
situation hat sie ihn eigentlich raus
geholfen sie hat ruhe in sein leben
gebracht und ihr netzwerk die politiker
die ihn dann ins amt gehoben haben die
sind dann überhaupt erst auf ihn
eingegangen
er konnte mit ihnen umgehen und dann
ging es los versetzt um die segensreiche
rolle von frau bismarck er wurde ja nun
862 preußischer ministerpräsident neun
jahre später hatte er das deutsche reich
geschaffen das war ja ein wahnsinns lauf
war das denn alles programmierte absicht
oder der steckte auch eine menge zu fall
dahinter stürmer wie immer in der
geschichte gibt es determinante und es
gibt freie elemente die sich entwickeln
sie müssen bedenken dass diese 60 er
jahren des 19 jahrhunderts sind die zeit
des amerikanischen bürgerkrieges die
aufmerksamkeit der welt war dahin
gerichte sie sind auch die jahre nach
dem krimkrieg in dem russland
australische russland
schwere niederlage erlebt und nicht in
der lage war anschließend große
europäische politik mit zugestellt das
heißt es öffnete sich eine möglichkeit
probleme zu lösen gewalttätig und
politisch die seit langem da waren der
dualismus österreich preußen geht tief
zurück ins 18 jahrhundert die schleswig
holstein frage um dieses jahr 1864 ging
hatte sich 1848 49 bereits massiv
gestellt in derselben besetzung einen
studenten und professoren unruhe
aufstand aufmarsch kriegerische
drohungen alles zu einer zeit als
bismarck einbeck besser war und sonst
gar nichts anderes ist ein glänzender
redner und der krieg mit frankreich ja
mein gott
der war auch der lag so in der luft das
ja auch das gesamte wirtschaftsgeschehen
das finanzgeschehen freundlichen nur
sitz mark oder wollte ihnen irgendwie
auf napoleon der dritte napoleon der
dritte wollte ihn überhaupt nicht
trainieren krank und konnte kaum zu
pferde sitzen vor schmerzen aber das
parlament das parlament so komisch das
klingt oder so unerwartet französische
parlament das französische und die
französische presse die tobte gegen den
kaiser diesen schwächling der den krieg
nicht suchte der doch eigentlich leicht
zu gewinnen war
das war dann alles noch her ein
tragischer irrtum der blutiger
tragischer irrtum
nach dem weg über frankreich wird ja nun
das deutsche kaiserreich geschaffen
bismarck skin war das denn ein reich das
alle wollten auch in süddeutschland oder
hatte es von anfang an ich sage mal
geburtsfehler
naja gut in die deutsche einheit die war
ja sozusagen auf dem tapet zeit den
sogenannten befreiungskriegen gegen
napoleon also 18 13 14 war das war das
ein thema was die gemüter bewegt und was
dann natürlich bei der 48er revolution
wie wir ja wissen mit dem
verfassungsentwurf der paulskirche mit
dem bau kirchenparlament war das wieder
auf dem tapet
reichs einigung die die paulskirche vor
schluss scheiterte ja damals an der
weigerung preußens preußen versuchte
dann nach der paulskirche einen eigenen
entwurf wird durchzusetzen der natürlich
so hat sich der darauf scheiterte
kunstgut das war ein thema was in der in
der welt war sicherlich auch in
süddeutschland vielleicht nicht so
ausgeprägt
in manchen bayerischen zonen oder soll
ich sagen grauen oder in oberbayern
niederbayern in franken sicherlich
stärker als in oberbayern
aber es war auch in süddeutschland
natürlich vor allem in baten die wollten
ja früh schon sich preußen anschließen
einfach auch aus dem schieren aus der
schieren furcht vor württemberg weil die
württemberger schießen immer auf paten
und hätten dann den bayern den preis
dauer gegeben wenn die still gerechnet
also es war schon war schon ziemlich
allgemein der verlangen das verlange zum
zu einheit
was war denn da letzten endes bismarcks
intention des schien ja doch mit der
reichsgründung die bürgerliche sehnsucht
nach deutsche einheit erfüllt war das
auch von anfang an den bismarck ideal
ein einheitliches deutschland und er
wollte er im herzen doch schon so etwas
wie ein von greußen dominiertes reich
manche nennen ist ja groß preußen bis zu
den alpen
natürlich ging auch gar nicht anders
erstmal sie müssen hier auf die
wirtschaftliche lage anstellen preußen
ist auch das klingt überraschend für
moderne vorurteile
preußen ist zu dieser zeit einen
zusammen mit großbritannien vormacht des
freihandels süddeutschland ist gegen
freihandel österreich ist total gegen
verhandelt um einen modernen
industriestaat zu bauen mit eisenbahnen
und mit entsprechende finanzausstattung
brauchen sie eine gewisse größe und
diese größe hatte preußen nicht preußen
neuer unserem staatsgebiet zerrissen
es gab ein rheinisches rheinischen teil
preußens dann kam hannover dazwischen
kurhessen und dann gab es das
eigentliche
um berlin brandenburg das eigentliche
preußen und das zusammenzuführen war
eine strategische aufgabe allerersten
ranges und war gewissermaßen diktiert
durch finanzen wirtschaftsinteressen
john maynard keynes hat gesagt durch
kohle und stahl ist dieses reich
zusammengekommen soll sich durch das
wort von eisen und blut nicht so völlig
vorführen und verwirren lassen
kohle und stahl bars und diese logik hat
die sache zusammengeführt und zumal ja
auch die gewerbeordnung des
norddeutschen bundes war eine
revolutionäre tat war sowie der code
civil in frankreich und die liegt ja vor
der reichsgründung mehrere jahre vor der
reichsgründung das ist da entsteht ein
reales deutschland - österreich
österreich war in dieses liberale
deutschland nicht einzubeziehen es ist
also eine der krieg von 86 ließ
entscheidungs krieg und zwar nicht um
zusammen zu bleiben so
auseinanderzugehen ganz ganz
ungewöhnlich in der weltgeschichte auf
ihre frage nach dem geburtsfehler
eingehen der geburtsfehler lag in der
verfassung des deutschen reiches
es ist also relativ schnell zu erklären
ja gerne kein problem
der souverän in unserer verfassung sind
mir das ist das volk aber der souverän
in der bismarckschen verfassung ist der
bundesrat gewesen nämlich die
versammlung der fürsten die souveräne
der einzelnen länder könige großherzöge
die haben sich zusammengetan und haben
dieses reich gegründet und was sie immer
geschah musste von ihnen abgelegt werden
das volk hatte da überhaupt nichts mit
zu mischen und es gab wohl ein reichstag
mit budget ja mit budgetrecht was ganz
wichtig ist und der reichstag musste
auch eine slim gesetzen zustimmen
aber der reichstag durfte keine selbst
keine vorlagen machen keine
gesetzesvorlagen und die parteien hatten
weiter überhaupt gar keinen einfluss das
heißt im kern der sache geht es
daraufhin aus es ist also jetzt bisschen
überspitzt gesagt aber um es klar zu
machen
es ist ein reich ohne volk gewesen die
leute waren zwar begeistert das fanden
sie wunderbar
aber politisch hatten sie sehr sehr
wenig zu melden
und das sind die dinge die sich dann
später am ende des ersten weltkrieges
sehr böse ausgezahlt vor langer zeit
einmal deutsch geschichte 19 jahrhundert
geschriebenen titel nationalismus wollen
nation und das war genau die these die
ich hatte dass das deutsche reich ein
nationalstaat war den die nation fehlte
und die hat bismarck in der tat eine
systematisch verhindert denken sie nur
etwa an den kampf gegen die karte gegen
den politischen katholizismus denken sie
nur an die sozialisten gesetze das war
er hat die innere reichs einigung nicht
vollzogen weil ihm auch die äußere
reichs ein reinigung eigentlich nicht am
herzen der stürmer sprach von der logik
von kohle und stahl aber das war wie ich
behaupten würde nicht die hand und logik
von bismarck bismarck war ein mann das
der ganz im 18 jahrhundert stand und
worum es bis mal gegen war preußen
großen stark zu machen die deutsche
einheit dass die dann sozusagen nebenbei
abfiel
das hat er dann hingenommen aber es ging
ihm immer nur um preußen das sollte
stark sein und das hat er ja erreicht es
preußen war der grösste gliedstaat im
deutschen reich und war die führende
macht militärisch wirtschaftlich alles
richtig aber ihm schwebte nie vor ein
nationalstaat zu schaffen
den hat er geradezu nach kräften zu
verhindern versucht das hat ja vor
hoffmann gerade gesagt wie das parlament
sozusagen nur eine dekorative roller
hatte weitgehend
er hat das ist ja die zeit danach gerne
sich häuser theodor mommsen hat ja in
seinen politischen manifest am end
geschrieben ich wünschte ein bürger zu
sein und damit meinen die ja genau
ein bürger im sinne des zittriger der
also mit das gemeinwesen mitgestaltet
mit frauen und das eben hat bismarck den
deutschen nicht gegeben dieses
gemeinwesen das
das frei klassenwahl recht kalt in
preußen bis zum ende des ersten
weltkriegs und ansonsten hatten wir zwar
das allgemeine männer wahlrecht aber
eben bei den eingeschränkten
möglichkeiten des reichstags imbiss mal
gleich war das halt einfach zu wenig sie
fühlten sich nicht richtig interpretiert
woraufhin ich finde ich etwas auf die
spitze treiben ist es immer gefährlich
dass dann nur noch weiter zuspitzen
aber was ich gerne sagen möchte ist dass
ich schon meine dass er stürmer auch
recht hat denn das sehen sie übrigens
auch in der verfassung die verfassung
ist zugleich wie eine arbeits agenda was
bismarck sich alles vornimmt post
telegraph also erstaunliche dinge stehen
in der verfassung was er alles machen
will mit einheitliches recht statt
sieben verschiedene währung eine währung
und das sind alles dinge die er gemacht
hat und mit der auch der wirtschaft die
wege geebnet hat ich würde die titel von
herrn stürmer nicht so vom tisch wischen
sondern ich meine wohl dass beide und
ich vielleicht auch recht haben bismarck
war natürlichen an großen reich von
allen seiten getragen darüber reden
natürlich in den zwei jahrzehnten die
nach der reichsgründung folgten hat der
kanzler bismarck ja dieses reich geprägt
adenauer hat ja mal schlicht gesagt
bismarck war ein guter außenpolitiker
und ein schlechter innenpolitiker hat er
recht nach aus adenau aussichten
rheinischer katholik beeinflusst von der
katholischen soziallehre der mochte
bräuche nicht mehr mochte preußen
sowieso nicht besonders die geschichte
hätte immer die vorhänge zugezogen im
zug nach berlin
dieses grauenhafte asien nicht ist
natürlich frei erfunden
denn erfuhr im schlafwagen und da
empfiehlt es sich die vorhänge
zuzuziehen
also klar wenn wir nicht haben dass mit
dem kultur kampf und das mit dem
sozialistengesetz ist zwar eine
sozusagen fest gemauerte kritik am
bismarck reich nur wenn sie es mal
vergleichen international der kultur
kampf hat die zivilehe eingeführt
scheidungsrecht familienrecht
und das ging gegen die katholische
kirche und ging auch gegen die
protestantische kirche
aber wenn sie es vergleichen wie es
andere völker gemacht im franzosen haben
tausende von priestern mitten in der
französischen revolution
um diese fragen abgeschlagen das gleiche
problem und es gibt bis heute
demokratische staaten die das genau
nicht haben diese trennung zwischen
kirche und staat
und wir legen größten wert darauf
außerdem dürfen sie nicht vergessen der
kulturkampf bricht aus 1871 als das
zentrum die zentrumspartei im reichstag
sagt das deutsche reich muss jetzt im
web für den vatikan intervenieren
truppen schicken
wie kamen sie auf die idee bis dahin war
der vatikan von franzosen geschützt
worden
die waren aber im krieg besiegt worden
und konnten und wollten nicht mehr
und nun sollte das deutsche reich das
tun absurd aber und hochgefährlich und
da beginnt der kulturkampf genau über
diese frage und beim sozialistengesetz
würde ich doch mal anmerken das
sozialistengesetz hat ja nicht den
sozialismus verboten
es hat nur die reichweite organisation
unterdrückt aber es ist niemand ins
gefängnis geworfen worden es ist niemand
erschossen erhängt und sonstwie
umgebracht wurden vergleicht es mit
frankreich 1848 massiver bürgerkrieg in
frankreich 1870 71 die schlacht um die
kommunen anschließend erschießt massen
erschießungen und auf die teufelsinsel
geschickt da das ist die welt in der man
bismarck und das bismarck reich
vergleichen analysieren bewerten muss
und dann relativiert sich vieles
also alles nicht so schlimm mit der
bösen innenpolitiker bismarck
nein da würde ich doch heftig
widersprechen ein stürmer man muss ja
nicht immer nur die schlimmsten
beispiele aus der zeit plus - 50 jahre
vorher oder so neben um dann zu sagen
also bei bismarck war ja alles viel
harmloser verglichen damit so das eine
das andere ist der kultur kampf fand ja
nicht statt weil bismarck uns mit der
ziviltrauung beschränken wollte oder mit
der bürgerlichen ehe scheidung sondern
der kultur kam fand ja vor allem oder
weil die zentrumspartei die ja so
mächtig und einflussreich damals ja noch
gar nicht wahr sagte deutschland muss
jetzt im vatikan intervenierenden armen
papst vor dem zugriff der italienischen
nationalisten schützen sondern der fun
statt weil bismarck einmal von seinem
naturell von seiner handlungslogik immer
so einen leichten bürgerkrieg brauchte
denen unter kontrolle haben konnte ich
zum zweiten weil ihm die zentrumspartei
natürlich absolut fremd und feind nicht
wahr weil das war die erste volkspartei
modern sind die organisierte nicht
bestimmte stände oder klassen sondern
die organisierte querbeet vom handwerker
bis zum katholischen industriellen von
polen bis zu über die welfen bis sonst
wohin die leute also sie war eine wenn
sie so wollen ein raichs partei zwar
keine agraria partei wie die preußischen
konservativen die nur in preußen ihre
paar stimmen hatten und da auch im
reichstag haben sie war nicht wie die
nationalliberalen oder national
miserablen eine klassen partei sondern
es war eine richtige volkspartei und das
war ein phänomen was bismarck mit seinem
gespür natürlich sofort fürchten und
sagt das ist eine große gefahr
die muss ich die muss ich ausrotten von
anfang an und hat natürlich dann den
kultur kampf als die große den sozusagen
ich sag jetzt was fatal ist den endsieg
des protestantismus
hier siegt luther und damit hat er
natürlich die nationalliberalen im boot
gehabt wie er sagt jetzt geht's endlich
mal gegen den katholizismus richtig voll
drauf das sind wir so schön dabei und
ich bin nur gegen die dämonisierung oder
kultur kampf ist in dem zug der
säkularisierung europäischer nationen un
staaten ein vergleichbare
prozess und dann erweist er sich als
nicht so ganz aus der luft gegriffen und
nicht so ganz nur innenpolitische taktik
sondern ein modernisierungsprozess
schmerzliche art der natürlich auch
manipuliert manipulativ gebraucht wurde
völlig einverstanden
der strom ist ein modernisierungsprozess
gewesen wäre was bismarck damit
bezweckte dann wäre es noch umgekehrt
viel sinnvoller gewesen er hätte im
sinne der inneren reichs einigung
das zentrum das die gruppen für die das
zentrum stand ins zentrum vertrat hätte
einbezogen später spät aber erstmal erst
einmal den kulturkampf gewissen härte
ausgeführten nun aber zehn jahre ich
bitte sie das ist das eine lange strecke
also es ist und danach war es vorbei
weil dann ging es gegen die sozialisten
dann musste er brauchte er ja das
zentrum als mehrheitsbeschaffer im
reichstag um dann sein sozialistengesetz
durchzusetzen also es ist wie man wie
man es dreht und wendet er hätte das
zentrum nutzen können um die innere
reichs einigung die ja bewusst vermieden
hat zu vollenden das war aber nicht sein
ziel sondern sein ziel war das große
innere reinigung das ist doch nicht ein
liederkranz harmonie sondern die innere
reichseinigung hat er frau hoffmann hat
es ja erwähnt zivilprozess um
strafprozessordnung gemeinsame münze
münz- und währungs gesetzgebung eine
reichsbank das ist alles innere
reinigung und sozusagen die große
harmonie die opposition durfte im
reichstag ja immerhin zu wort kommen und
hat dem bismarck schlaflose nächte
buchstäblich bereitet die und es war ja
auch nicht so dass die opposition im
reichstag überhaupt nicht zu wort kam
baum hat den bismarck so viel getan um
immer wieder mehrheiten
zusammenzubringen
er brauchte diese mehrheit
das war nicht der absolutismus und
fröhlich dem großen ich würde mich herr
stürmer ich würde die sozialisten
gesetze wohl nicht so verharmlosen wie
sie das gemacht habe ich sie richtig
verstanden haben wie nicht sagen es ist
es ist wenn sie vergleichen mit dem
umgang mit sozialisten und
gewerkschaften in großbritannien und
frankreich
und das sind die vergleichsmaßstäbe in
der zeit dann kommt das bismarck reich
so übel nicht weg da noch die
sozialgesetzgebung hinzufügen müssen aus
den 80er jahren
wenn ich es aber vergleiche mit der
zunahme der stimmen sie für die
sozialdemokratie abgegeben worden sind
dann also jetzt nicht mit anderen
ländern sondern mit dem was in
deutschland passiert dann hat man doch
sehr stark den eindruck dass das
bismarck die sozialdemokratie abgewürgt
hat gerade bereits 1800 grund vielleicht
können sie ja wohl nicht abgewürgt
worden sein
die spd von heute wieder irgendwo ein
drittel aller stellen die sozialisten
gesetzt waren ja nicht 1890 sondern die
waren erheblich früher schüler ja genau
erheblich früher und als die mehrheit im
reichstag sozialdemokratisch war da hat
sich die ganze situation aber es war
aber so dass die sozialisten gesetze
verhindert haben dass die spd als partei
arbeiten konnte es gab doch jeder
abgeordnete arbeit machen
sie durften keine reklame machen keine
reden halten es war alles verboten da
nur auf dieses leben aber viel wahlkreis
ebene durften sie ja das war ein
kompliziertes gesetz und es waren
sozusagen ja keine brutale
hundertprozentigen verfolgung war ein
sehr doppeldeutige 's gesetz einmal die
werbende wirkung der sozialgesetzgebung
zum zweiten in den wahlkreisen durften
ja die sozialdemokratischen kandidaten
auftreten
die arbeit machen aber ich bitte sie was
ist partei aber die haben reden gehalten
haben druckschriften verteilt die haben
den arbeiter bismarck august bebel
gefeiert die sind rom gereist
fünf mal so zu sein dass ich sag mal ist
kein verfolgungen des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts hat man anderes gesehen
das wollen nur ganz kurz ein band zur
inneren reinigung machen wenn sie das
münz wesen anführen lieber stürmer
müssten wir heute bei der europäischen
einigung unendlich weit sein weil wir
zahlen seit über zehn jahren mit dem eu
nur mit dem euro mit dem mit allem was
die förderung einige idee ist weiter
weiter entfernt denn je nein ich sage
ihnen eins polemisch die reichs einigung
die inneren reichs einigung spahn stadt
im ersten weltkrieg gefallen die stadt
und nicht vorher
da das war der moment aber nochmal euro
der euro ja das hat ja 1990 eine große
rolle gespielt indem gesagt wurde aber
unter bismarck ist das doch auch
wunderbar gelaufen unter bismarck war
die währung silber und gold punkt und
diese ganzen papier man manipulationen
durch zentralbanken waren wir völlig
undenkbar sondern das geld lag in den
fässern im keller hier in spandau für
preußen und sonst hatte man eben seinen
staatsschatz und wenn sie bei silber bei
silber geld ist völlig egal welche
welcher radler oder welche figur da
draufsteht sie können das durch sie
können das wiegen echtem schrot und korn
wohl dass die münze echtes schott und
com kommen wir auf dieser basis nun für
außenpolitik bismarck hat ja selber mal
gesagt nach der reichseinigung das
deutsche reich sei nunmehr saturiert war
das denn nur eine phrase um die anderen
mächte in europa zu beruhigen
oder war es wirklich so in seinem
selbstverständlich
ein saturiert das friedliches reich wird
ja gelegentlich hier als hinter seine
karten des deutschen reiches
eingeblendet sieht man ja was das ein
gewaltiger koloss war und freiburg ich
nehme ja von davon von von den vogesen
bis mir ja ja also dass ich meine des
kämmerers elsass lothringen noch dazu
und das war ja ein gewaltiger koloss und
das war genau das die antithese zu dem
was der wiener kongress 1815 gemacht
hatte weil das war die alte überlegung
die mitte europa ist also deutschland
muss so stark sein dass die mitte sich
einmal gegen frankreich und zum anderen
gegen russland erfolgreich zur wehr
setzen kann
aber sie muss in sich zu schwach seien
um eigenständige machtpolitik zu treiben
das war damit mit dem deutschen reich
von bismarck nicht mehr gegeben dass die
israeli übrigens damals gleich als die
große unerhörte revolution kennzeichnete
das war jetzt ein großer machtblock in
der mit europa sind wir das ganze
europäische mächte gleichgewicht aus der
balance brachte und das war der
entscheidende fehler bismarck musste
jetzt versuchen wir diesen koloss mit
dem übrigen europa irgendwie verbinden
konnte ohne assist zum konflikt der
koloss in der mitte europas sebastian
haffner hat ja mal geschrieben
dieses reich war zu groß für das
harmonische konzert der mächte in europa
und zu klein um über sie zu herrschen
wird ja gerne zitiert war das denn
erstens so und wenn ja was die quelle
allen übels na ja es kam noch einige
andere belastungen zuerst mal die
annexion von elsass und lothringen war
deshalb ein riesenfehler weil es das
5 system des das europa des europäischen
gleichgewichts an einer entscheidenden
stelle blockierte bismarck hat mal
gesagt in einem system von fünf nächten
muss man immer schauen dass man zu dritt
ist frankreich hatte damit aber eine
stellung gegenüber dem deutschen reich
die sehr gefährlich war für das bismarck
schuhwerk das brauchte ja nur eine
verbindung zu russland entstehen die
jetzt an tatsächlichen gefolge des
berliner kongresses auch entstand und
die bismarck nicht mehr bewältigen
konnte von da an war es ein system von
aushilfen und im grunde war es das von
anfang an der große außenpolitiker
bismarck war ist im grunde an seinem
eigenen werk gescheitert stichwort
elsass lothringen die quelle allen übels
ich meine man man konnte es keine
diskussionen damals sollen wir das rein
nehmen sollen wir nicht
nun konnte man ja sagen damals haben ja
auch einige gesagt die deutschen hat
sich ja damit nur zurück geholt was die
franzosen ihnen ende des 17 jahrhunderts
geraubt
da konnte ich meinen hätte man hat
dialog hätte man auch die schweiz und
die niederlande reinholen können und so
weiter nein das war natürlich der große
fehler gebe ich ein stürmer völlig recht
das war der große fehler weil damit war
frankreich für alle zeiten außen vor
aber ich glaube bismarck hat das gar
nicht weiter gesteckt weil mit
frankreich mit einem republikanischen
frankreich würde ich behaupten hatte er
sowieso nichts am hut weil er war
legitim ist bis in die knochen und
deshalb lange er der chef war weil er
der schäfer und deshalb hat er nur mit
russland und österreich immer gepackt
was natürlich eine in sich eine
idiotie weil das man zwei mächte die
sehr starke interessengegensätze auf dem
balkan hatten wo deutschland überhaupt
kein interesse hatte und dann mit beiden
gut freund zu sein und beide auseinander
zu halten dass sie sich da auf dem
balkan nicht in die haare kriegen wollen
das war natürlich eine ein unterfangen
das bismarck dann auf mindestens so
viele schlaflose nächte gekostet hat ist
der katholizismus der unendlichkeit des
großen fast gescheitert ist und was
gescheitert absolut gescheitert ja aber
letzten endes gehört es doch zum
populären klischee dass unter bismarck
ja dieses spiel mit den diversen bällen
in europa doch nur halbwegs funktioniert
hat rückversicherungs vertrag mit
russland und erst unter seinen unfähigen
nachfolgern so das populäre klischee ist
die ganze sache auseinander gefallen ist
das von seiner persönlichen genialität
auch ein bisschen abhängig gewesen
dieses komplizierte system in europa ja
er hat er natürlich ein enormes prestige
er hat ja auch der schrecken europas das
ist natürlich maßlos übertrieben
es gab dem berliner kongress und da
hatten dies mag europa vor einem
gewaltigen krieg nämlich großbritannien
british empire gegen das zahlreich
gerettet es ist ihm nicht gedankt worden
ist den deutschen haupt nicht gedankt
worden
russische außenpolitik zu dieser zeit
war nicht von dankbarkeit geprägt
sondern von kanzler wyss muss drang zu
den dardanellen erbe der türkei
das damit ist er nicht fertig geworden
und hat noch eins drauf gesessen da sind
wir wieder bei der politik er musste
jedenfalls glaubt er dass er musste
etwas tun für den agrarsektor und zwar
nicht nur für den adel und den land bis
den land besitzenden sozusagen die
regierenden klassen sollen für die masse
der bäuerlichen anwesen in deutschland
ist ein agrarstaat bis in die ganz späte
bismarck zeit und das ist eine agrar
soziale frage und da hat man die zelle
eingeführt diese zölle haben natürlich
die russischen heute würde man sagen
ukrainischen exporte massiv behindert
die konnten ihre schulden auf den kauf
der klitsche nicht mehr bezahlen und
damit wurde es einem existenziellen
problem und damit wird sozusagen
zwischen dem russischen panzer wyss muss
und der französischen revanche das
bündnis geschlossen und nun hat bis man
alles wiederum getan um dieses bündnis
aufzubrechen dazu gehört der
rückversicherung vertrag es er hat alles
getan auch um frankreich zu bestätigen
und zu sagen wir unterstützen euch wo
immer er in der welt kolonien haben
wollten wir sind für euch und am nicht
die geringsten bedenken dagegen
und das problem wird russland aber bis
mainz friedenspolitik hat ja auch großen
erfolg gehabt
sie gehen jetzt hier alle sehr schnell
vorwärts und gucken gleichzeitig
rückwärts und schieben die jahre etwas
zusammen wenn man das deutsche reichen
seine entwicklung anguckt dann muss man
doch sagen dass bismarck in den ersten
jahren viel erfolg hatte zum beispiel
dass der berliner kongress hier in
berlin stattfand auf bitten russlands
das waren große erfolge england war da
österreich weiter frankreich war da er
hat wunderbar diese probleme gelöst aus
damaliger sicht lässt er heute ich dass
wir heute anders darüber urteilen und
dass wir wissen was daraus geworden ist
zum teil durch eingebaute fehler zum
teil der zufall dass es etwas anderes
aber bismarck wollte nachdem das reicht
da war absolutes liegen haben um das ist
ihnen heute immer die balance und es ist
im auskühlung
die bestellungen aber sicher ist es ihm
gelungen es hat ja keinen krieg geben zu
lassen
auch diese geschichte dass man sagt
preußen ist so groß in der mitte europas
das sich in erster linie als gefahr aber
es ist nicht zum tragen gekommen denn
das deutsche reich oder umgekehrt
bismarcks scheitern und der wilhelm dem
zweiten in den anfangsjahren hat neben
vielen gründen das hat nicht nur einen
grund
als grund eben nicht dass der posten zu
groß gewesen ist sondern dass die
verfassung was anderes vorgesehen hat
das verhältnis reichskanzler zugreise
das war der das grundübel des deutschen
reiches und diese anderen geschichten
hat bismarck versucht in der balance zu
halten und auch wilhelm hätte das noch
geschafft wenn er nicht mit seiner
nibelungentreue und seinem
großmannssucht und der den leuten mit
denen es sich um geben hatte
durchgetreten gutes stichwort es gibt ja
in deutschland die tendenz heute und
über jahrzehnte hinweg bismarck in
schutz zu nehmen und den weg in den
abgrund aus der weltkrieg vor allem dem
ungestümen wesen von wilhelm dem letzten
anzulassen jetzt frage ich sie mal
erwähnt auch ein bisschen provokativ
wieviel bismarck steckt in diesem
deutschen weg der nacht 19 14 18 und ich
sag jetzt mal ganz bewusst nach 33 45
fördern
ich behaupte ja dass da einiges drin
steckt ich meine wenn sie nochmal die
die bismarck das bismarck bündnissystem
nehmen das war ja das war ja doch eine
verlogenheit ich versuche ja vorhin zu
sagen das war ein glasperlenspiel das
auch mit bismarck irgendwann scheitern
musste in diesen verträgen waren immer
geheim klauseln drin die sozusagen
anderen verträgen direkt widersprachen
das war geld für den für den pakt mit
russland da die wii anderes mehr
er widersprach dem dem zweirad bündnis
mit österreich das war das war eine
katastrophe das musste irgendwann zur
explosion kommen was war davon natürlich
die bismarck hat ja die ganze
beamtenschaft in preußen im auswärtigen
amt in den anderen
ist er war ja so lange an der macht der
hat diese leute geprägt da die mit
seinem geist geprägt und die setzt ihre
arbeit fort der geheimrat holstein war
ja nicht eine kreatur sozusagen eigene
schöpfung sondern es war auch eine
kreatur gewissermaßen von bismarck der
die außenpolitik dann als graue eminenz
in wilhelminischer zeit betrieb nein das
war alles dahinter steckt es sehr viel
bismarck drin und das hat sich natürlich
verschlimmert und verschärft durch die
figur von william dem plötzlichen der
gemeinde er könne da jetzt selbst als
herrscher die direktiven geben und jetzt
eigene außenpolitik machen und dann
kommt noch die flottenpolitik diese
unzählige dazu und so weiter und so
weiter und so weiter
also da gibt es schon sehr viele
kontinuität für die wir bismarck nicht
aus der verantwortung entlassen
diesmal auf die spitze ich versuch's
macht die spitze zu treiben damit war
klar darüber diskutieren jetzt haben
jahrzehnte nach dem tode bismarck die
nazis hitler als eine art von legitimen
erben bismarck stilisiert gibt es in der
tat in dieser kontinuität einen weg von
bismarck zu hitler
nein natürlich nicht dass es eines nazi
propaganda dass die anja auf dieses
plakat gehabt was der große könig usw
eroberte der große kanzler und so weiter
das wird der führer jetzt überhaupt so
weiter das ist natürlich dummes zeug ich
habe ja nur gesagt weil eine weile der
eindruck entstand dass zwischen bismarck
und hitler jahrhunderte deutscher
geschichte lagen dass das dass da eine
kontinuität gibt es das viel kürzer war
dass ein mann wie hinten burg der bei
königgrätz 1866 als polnischer leuten
mittwoch der 1871 im spiegelsaal von
versailles bei der kaiser proklamation
zugegen war
der 1914 15 die abwehrschlachten bei
tannenberg gegen die russin geschlagen
hat das eben dieser hindenburg dann 1933
durchaus im einklang mit der verfassung
das war nicht sein sein
aigner sein eigener einfall den hitler
zum reichskanzler gemacht hat gut das
zeigt doch das war's
dazwischen war nicht ich sage nichts
anderes als dass dazwischen nicht
jahrhunderte lagen sondern es gab da
natürlich auch personelle kontinuitäten
denken sie nur an die beamtenschaft die
ich schon anführte
es gab da natürlich kontinuität in der
denke denken sie nur an die grenzen
bismarckturm die gebaut wurden dass man
der mann war gerade in schwerer zeit wie
wir sie nach dem ersten weltkrieg in
deutschland hat natürlich ein leuchtturm
an dem man sich klammert das war alles
das spielt alles eine rolle das kann man
nicht einfach so wegwischen das spielt
alles atmosphärisch mit hinein ich sage
nicht dass hitler ein wiedergänger von
bismarck war keineswegs dass das war mit
wirklichen das war wirklich nicht
mittlerweile schon ein
ein schurke sui generis aber
kontinuitäten kontinuität aber es gibt
doch dies konnte die geschichte besteht
immer aus einer mischung aus kontinuität
und diskontinuität das können sie weiß
gott als zeitgenossen des jahres 1990
sehen und es gibt auch manchmal replays
nicht komplett aber die geschichte
steckt voller überraschungen und die
diskontinuität möchte ich jetzt mal
nachdem herr willens die kontinuität
betonen möchte die diskontinuität
betonen bismarck war überaus
zurückhaltend mit kolonie er wollte sie
überhaupt nicht 1890 hat er gesagt am
liebsten würde ich einem hamburger
kaufmanns konsortium den ganzen kolonial
quatsch geben für eine mark bei ihm war
chef der admiralität 1 in verträgen aral
was war die aufgabe der deutschen flotte
truppentransport aber weiß gott nicht
großbritannien herauszufordern
sozusagen der klar in der weltklasse der
weltmächte das kommt von tirpitz her und
damit aus dem bürgertum das kommt von
william dem zweiten und das war nach
elsass lothringen vielleicht der nächste
kapitalfehler was sebastian haffner
übrigens auch so gesehen hat wir sind
was der alte fürst metternich nannte
eine saturierte macht das halt bismarck
im reichstag gesagt signalisieren den
russen gegenüber
haltet ruhe sei zufrieden mit dem status
quo wenn es um den balkan geht und um
die dardanellen dann müssen wir uns
irgendwie einigen auf kosten der türkei
das ist ein wörtliches zitat er hat
alles getan um großbritannien sozusagen
auf der deutschen seite zu halten und
das war gar nicht so undenkbar
zwischen großbritannien russland gab es
gewaltige kriegs nahe ereignisse und
reibung zwischen großbritannien und
frankreich gab es auch weiß gott
genügend gefahrensituationen
das läuft ja nicht zwanghaft wie in
einer einbahnstraße monokausal auf den
ersten weltkrieg zu sondern bismarck war
sich ja gerade der brüchigkeit dieser
konstruktion sehr bewusst daher immer
wieder der versuch mit großbritannien zu
dritt zu sein
österreich ungarn er sah die brüchigkeit
und daher kommt dann auch das berühmte
wort vom balkan der der ganze balkan es
nicht die heilen knochen eines pornos
und musketeers wird das war nicht nur
ein bonmot das war ein starkes signal an
österreich ersten wir schlagen uns nicht
für euch was ja genau der fehler von
unserem 14 war und zweitens an russland
wir haben auf dem balkan keine
existenziellen interessen war es dann
aber so dass unter bismarck die sache in
europa noch halbwegs gut lief und erst
nach seiner absetzung der lotse geht von
bord sehen wir ja hinter ihm immer
gelegentlich dieses berühmte bild aus
band die sache schief lief unter seinen
unfähigen nachfolger
so sehe ich das ich möchte gerne zu
dieser nazi geschichte noch etwas
hinzufügen nur zu dem was sie sagten was
die sache vollkommen auseinander kegelt
es gab keinen rassen waren es gab keine
rassenkunde es gab keine rassen zucht
anstalten
es gab keine idee den osten zu erobern
und platz für ein deutsches käme also
für ein germanisches volk zu schaffen
und was auch ganz wichtig war es gab
keine parallele organisationen zu den
ministerien also partei leute die
parallel in die misston
die stelen rein wirtschaftlichen bzw das
ansicht zu aber jetzt wieder zu ihrer
frage ich sagte ihnen es geht immer ein
ganz klein bisschen schnell
ich denke schon dass bismarck aus seiner
zeit gesehen und gemessen an seinen
zeitgenossen das doch recht gut gemacht
hat und das problem für viele war denke
ich mir dass er so sehr lange 28 jahren
ministerpräsident war 19 jahre
reichskanzler war das lag eben auch
daran dass kaiser wilhelm gehalten hat
und das ist eben als reichskanzler
es lag ich komme immer darauf zurück an
die verfassung der kaiser hat den
kanzler ernannt und der kanzler hat den
anderen gesagt russland geht und wir
können uns freuen unsere großeltern
konnten sich freuen dass es gut ging
das ist gut gehen in der aktuellen krise
in europa werden ja da und dort und vor
allem auch gelegentlich in südeuropa
gerne mal parallelen gezogen zwischen
bis max reich und der rolle deutschlands
heute als ja eine art von nicht so ganz
geliebter hegemon leben wir denn in
einem bismarck reich 2.0 aber ich glaube
nicht dass frau merkel die verehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin merkel ein bismarck
kredit eine bismarck ready viva ist
sozusagen uns dann auch korrekt
lateinisch zu machen
das ist unfug ich glaube auch nicht dass
das das deutsche interesse sein sollte
dass wir wieder in so einer situation
kommen dass wir nicht ein bismarck reich
deutschland in europa ist sondern eine
bis marktposition in europa hat ich
glaube das sollte mir gar nicht erst
versuchen mit diesen gedanken sollten
wir auch nicht spielen
ich finde es sehr richtig weil das würde
bedeuten dass wir dann auch gleichzeitig
wieder nach osten hin offener werden
dass wir uns dann wieder an russland
anlehnen an diesen putin in dem ich
zutiefst misstraut und ich sage es ist
eine der größten errungenschaften und
der größten nie einer der größten
gewinner aus dem verlust des zweiten
weltkriegs ist die endgültige
westbindung das war die große leistung
von konrad adenauer und da sollten wir
bitteschön nicht dran rühren die
endgültige westbindung aber wenn sie in
der deutschen bevölkerung ich habe jetzt
nicht die aktuellen demoscope
parat aber in den letzten monaten dass
sich mal anschauen da gibt es hier an
die diskrepanz zwischen der meinung der
leute und der aktuellen politik in
berlin denn für die leute ist so eine
ungefähre bindung an russland sympathie
für russland egal was der putin da so
treibt unterschwellig vorhanden da ist
ja eine diskrepanz stürmer naja die
ukraine ist ja erst seit 1999 ein
selbstständiger staat und wie
selbstständig kann niemand genau angeben
es gibt da ein gewisses verständnis für
die historischen wunden russlands bei
der bevölkerung mehr als in der politik
und vielleicht ist das ein großer fehler
vielleicht hat die bevölkerung diesmal
mehr recht als die politik ich bin da
eher geteilter meinung was die leute
übersehen ist dass die heutige position
deutschlands in europa natürlich
balanciert wird und legitimiert wird und
unterstützt wird durch die präsenz
amerikas ohne amerika gibt es keine
europäische sicherheitspolitik weder
materiell als ausstattung mit hardware
noch geistig noch in irgendeiner weise
es gibt kein europäisches
sicherheitssystem die lädt eigentlichen
kern die eigentlichen garantie faktoren
sind noch immer wie im kalten krieg
amerikanische nuklearwaffen so
schockierend dass jetzt natürlich klingt
das vergessen die leute und das sagt
ihnen ja auch kaum jemand nur für putin
ist das ein element der balance deshalb
kann die nato bis an die ränder des
russischen reiches das modernen russland
gehen und die
baltischen staaten ein mitziehen
bismarck hätte sich da herausgehalten
das ist überhaupt keine frage
vordringen der nato bis an die russische
grenze finde ich auch fatal aber was man
fördern sollte wäre das vordringen der
europäischen union bis an die grenze das
ist friedlich was haben konnten in der
ukraine 7 und krachig da nur sagen würde
das sollte man sich gut überlegen denn
wir haben schon genug ausgänge einige
und wir sollten nicht dann wieder gutes
geld in eine in ein bodenloses fass
werfen und die ukraine ist das im
übrigen ist ja die ukraine eine deutsche
erfindung wie sie wissen der stürmer
presley topstar ich da nur da würde ja
die ukraine in den vertreten den frieden
verpasste das deutsche reich und
österreich mit sowjetrussland damals
schon schlossen wurde ja die ukraine und
auch die baltischen staaten sind damals
eine deutsche erfindung als die
baltischen staaten sind natürlich viel
älter sind sind viel älter völlig
richtig aber sie wurden da wieder
unabhängig nachdem sie vorher wie polen
auch sozusagen unter dem russischen
schirm standen unter der knute schuljahr
minuten vor dem ende noch mal zurück zu
bismarck als person frau hoffmann der
hat ja nach seiner absetzung kräftig an
seinem eigenen denkmal mit gemüse diese
vielen denkmäler die nach seinem tode
dann in deutschland dann errichtet
worden sind ihm zu ehren war denn dieser
nachruhm der ihn zukam
auch balsam noch zu seinen lebzeiten
balsam auf die wunden eines wir vorhin
gehört haben hochsensiblen liebhabers
wissen sie eigentlich was sich zu seinem
achtzigsten geburtstag abgespielt hat es
sind hunderttausende seiner
friedrichsruh bekommen es hat allein 28
postbeamte gegeben die den ganzen tag
briefe und telegramme sortiert haben es
sind sonderzüge gekommen
die magnifica enzen der deutschen
universitäten sind aufgetaucht tausende
von studenten
das sind alles dinge die bismarcks
selber befördert hat
also 5 eifrige leute um sich gesammelt
journalisten leute die hier die sich
ausgedacht haben was sie da nun alles
machen könnten also dieser nachruhm den
er bekommen hat
auch wenn ihn sicher nicht jeder akzent
gefahren hätte nämlich mal an
aber das sind im grunde sinnlose
spekulation denn nach um insgesamt hätte
ihm sehr sehr gut gefallen
meine schlussfolgerung wir alle und sie
haben jetzt ruhig ein bisschen zeit für
die schlussfrage ich guck mal auf die
uhr
neben adenauer gilt ja bismarck heute
bei den deutschen
ich zitiere als der größte deutsche
staatsmann das ist demoskopisch
untermauert ist das bloße mythos oder
eine durchaus richtige geschichtsdeutung
herr stürmer die leute sind nicht
unheimlich
sie suchen ja nicht eine figur die aus
so seinen mix zwischen jesus und gar nie
ist und dann noch ein bisschen politik
da drin soll sie suchen einen
politischen lieder in seinem widerspruch
und den haben sie in bismarck bekommen
der immerhin 30 jahre deutscher und
europäischer geschichte mitgeprägt hat
sehr stark geprägt hat und unter dem
nachdem einmal diese serie von drei sehr
unterschiedlichen kriegen durchgefochten
war ja alles getan hat um vom deutschen
reich die folgen dieser dramatischen
spannungs starken blutigen gründung
abzuwenden
das und es ist die sogenannte gute alte
zeit
da gab es keine inflation es gab
wachstum
es gab eine riesige transformation eines
agrar starts in einen industriestaat
deutschland das deutschland des jahres
des hasen so 13 ist eindeutig
industriestaat
das alles ist unter bismarck vorbereitet
worden
durch die modernisierungs gesetzgebung
strafprozess ich habe vorhin schon
erwähnt
die münze die
reichsbank und so weiter das ist
empfunden worden als sozusagen nicht
eine gabe bismarcks aber bismarck
präsidiert über dem ganzen mythologisch
fast und dafür war man dankbar und auch
bei aller opposition während des
bismarck reis und danach es war aus der
sicht der jahre danach nach 1914 die
gute alte zeit mit all ihren wunden und
stunden hoffen
ich meine schon dass er der grösste
deutsche politiker des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts im 20ten haben wir denn mit
der westbindung wir haben willy brandt
mit der ost bindung oder mit der mit der
versöhnung nach osten
wir haben kohl der die wiedervereinigung
hier in schwung gebracht und die teuer
großen bundeskanzler zu sich in einer
folge bis max das geht mir zu schnell
dass dazu möchte ich nicht ein viertel
aber ich möchte antworten dazu dass
leute ihn gut finden zu denen ich auch
gehöre bismarck ist ja nicht nur dieser
machtpolitiker gewesen sondern er ist
eben auch bekannt durch die briefe die
er geschrieben hat
er ist bekannt da habe ich viel auf
andere leute angegangen ist es bekannt
als jemand der markige sprüche
losgelassen hat er ist zwar auf der
einen seite ein sehr depressive mensch
gewesen der staat von seiner frau und
ihrer liebe und anerkennung abhängig war
aber auf der anderen seite ist doch ein
sehr witziger und intellektueller mensch
gewesen der viel unterhaltsames hat und
das nimmt einem jahr auch für ihn ein
und es gibt diese wunderbaren biografien
von gail von kolb die erschließen ein
bismarck von willen von helden jetzt
naja dämon der deutschen würde ich ja
ich denke einfach dass konnte so ein
bisschen für die titel ihrer bücher so
ein bisschen rückwärtsgewandt gewandte
fantasy literatur
alles ganz tolle verkaufs titel zu denen
man nur gratulieren kann
aber man darf die die thesen nicht
darauf verengt so ist es überhaupt
sollte ich das ruhelose reicht dazu
stehe ich und zwar das ruhelose bismarck
ich gar keine frage es war ein reich in
ein enorm in einer europäischen und
globalen phase der industrialisierung
darauf musste man antworten finden man
hat keine antworten sozusagen nach der
politik correctness des jahres 2015
gefunden
ammann hat verhältnismäßig humane
lösungen gefunden nachdem einmal die
grund konflikte die alle viel älter
waren wir alle übernommen hat nachdem
einmal diese grund konflikte mit den
mitteln der zeit die nicht so ganz
angenehm waren gelöst waren eine politik
des der friedens bewahrung ganz gewiss
und das ist ja schon etwas wofür man
nicht dankbar genug sein kann
das stehe mit solchen umfragen immer auf
kriegsfuß und wenn ich in münster
treffern immer sehen was die deutschen
zudem oder jeden meinen dann wachsen da
die turbon da ich immer was ist das für
ein blödsinn
wissen sie der lichtenberg der deutsche
aufklärer lichtenberg sagt er einmal auf
einem viehmarkt stadt alle welt auf den
fettesten ochsen und wir haben wir nur
weißbrot veranda weiß gott keine große
auswahl an staatsmännern zu bieten nicht
also das fängt bei uns eben mit bismarck
an und hört dann jetzt mit angela merkel
auf die ist ja noch im amt die wollen
wir nicht historisierend schon auf dem
podest dass sie so in diese richtung
rhein
wie wir schon da reingehen nicht allein
schon das ist eine frage des gender weil
es ist die erste frau die muss einfach
dann auch einen auf dem treppchen ganz
oben stehen weil sonst wird frau
hoffmann da sofort protest ich wollte
nur sagen wir haben ja keine keine so
große auswahl wie etwa die franzosen die
können ja bei der revolution anfangen
was fängt an mit mirabeau das geht dann
munter weiter mit pries sodann kommt zum
schuss dann controller kommt und alle
und das geht so munter weiter
der blutige gesehen völlig richtig aber
bedeutende für viele leute auch heute
noch auf der französischen linken die
sich identifizieren sich ja denken sie
an mail an frau ist doch dort einmal
robespierre das so ist das einfach
wir haben diese beschränkte ausfallen
dass der biss man natürlich den wir
überall als denkmal stehen sehen und
dann guckt man darauf besteht bis man
den gibt's sogar als ehering
es ist also ich meine das ist doch klar
dass ein bismarck ein feld aus
wer hat diesen mann nicht
also es ist ich sage ja nur der unfug
solcher umfragen kommt da so deutlich
zum ausdruck dass die leute für sich
aussprechen klar der ist nur jedem
bewusst sein auch wenn er damals noch
nicht geboren war und bis man eben weil
das die grosse figur ist die überall an
jeder ecke steht großartig aber ich sage
ich meine das sagt überhaupt nichts
natürlich war bismarck ein bedeutender
deutscher politiker und das wollen wir
auch gar nicht das wollen wir gar nicht
kleinreden er war auch gewiss ein
witziger mann er war ein gebildeter mann
er hat wunderbar reden gehalten dass
träumte ich mir heute dass man soll ein
redner im bundestag hätte haben wir
nicht vielleicht alarm hat aber ich will
nicht sagen dass er sonst ähnlichkeit
mit bismarck habe ich mit herrn lammert
zu tun also kurze gut eine bedeutende
figur und ich glaube wir haben ihm zum
zweihundertsten geburtstag noch manche
facette vergoldet und das soll auch so
sein so sei es denn geschichte ist die
lüge auf dem man sich geeinigt hat so
sagt das wollte er wir sehen das völlig
anders und ihnen ein danke ich sehr
für ihre interessanten aussagen und
ihnen liebe zuschauer dann gehe ich für
ihr interesse
bleiben sie uns treu